whoa this came from my body when I was
younger I had so much crazy earwax that
the doctor had to like flood this [ __ ]
out of my ear and it was like this huge
thing of earwax I'd say you clean my
hair is regularly I use q-tips once in a
while I was in a crazy earwax video
recently where they pulled out a raisin
sized earwax oh now I'm afraid that I'm
gonna be known as that your wax guy see
this is nice it's got like a friendly
little q-tip man on it I mean they look
medically sound except this guy with a
face on it it is so determined to clean
my ear oh look at this I'm guessing the
sticky part is the pink side so sticky
just look at this caution never insert
into or probe past the outer ear I think
I got this I'll start up here see if I
can just like get like the outer brim oh
it feels weird
I don't know how hard to press cuz I
don't want it sticking to the walls of
my ear I'm kind of spinning it kind of
like how you would make cotton candy ah
there we go that's the spot thank you
even talk right now it's a little firm
but it almost feels like a soft foam
let's see there's like small little like
dunking it the sticky thing is kind of
cool because the ones that I have at
home are super like cottony it's just
like fluff that you're putting in your
ears so I guess it's like easier to get
it stuck
hmm I mean it pulls the chunks out more
than just like smearing it around oh my
gosh you want to get a close-up of this
time for the white part clean that out
there we go mmm that's nasty
ah that's who this makes it unsticky I
don't know if anything sticking to it
huh feel like that's normal
I mean it used to be much more than this
it doesn't have chunks so at least
that's good just stained yellow my ears
are clean when I was told that these are
adhesive I thought I was going in
tape in my ears and these felt like
little kisses from butterflies I think
the stickiness kind of like helped the
white part stick to all the other things
in my ear the pink side pulled out more
chunks then the non sticky side the non
sticky side just kind of smears it it's
definitely super satisfying to just look
at it and be like woah this came from my
body I felt like I could go a little bit
further into my outer ear because I
wasn't worried about cotton getting
stuck in it which is amazing this might
be worth a try if you have trouble with
your ears and can't see a doctor yet mmm
that's nasty
[Music]
[Music]